denn mein thema ist eine regel die das
studentenparlament der universität
berlin der humboldt-universität berlin
sich 2018 ausgedacht hat und zwar dürfen
da jetzt männer in debatten nur noch
dann was sagen wenn vorher eine frau
gesprochen hat wenn nur noch männer sich
melden dann darf keiner was sagen das
gespräch ist beendet ich glaube aber
studieren ist dafür da dass man denken
lernt dass man ein echten diskurs hat
und ich glaube diese regel ist komplett
verblendet die viele andere in dieser
gender ideologie auch und damit bin ich
nicht einverstanden
viktor wachs da kann ich dir nur
zustimmen absolut applaus wenn das
erlaubt wäre hier oder ich mache es
einfach absolut richtig also dass ich
ein parlament
eine regel auferlegt die die freie rede
quasi ausschließt wenn nur ein
bestimmter teil derjenigen die dort
teilnehmen oder im parlament sitzen mit
macht und das auch noch an geschlechtern
orientiert das ist das wäre wenn man das
überträgt in den bundestag
beispielsweise herr plus oder auch in
die wissenschaft das wäre der tod dieser
demokratie so einfach muss man das sagen
es muss die möglichkeit geben
aufzustehen und was zu sagen es muss
auch die möglichkeit geben zu sagen ich
bin jetzt mal ruhig aber daran darf doch
eine debatte geführt wird nicht
scheitern oder
stattfinden also das kann auch nicht das
kriterium sein also das ist so was von
mir fehlen die worte gestrig also der
demokratie gefährde das ist eine sünde
die frauen frauen kann doch selber sich
durchsetzen und das das drückt den sohn
der heute zeigt dass in jeder jahre hier
sitzt jedoch nicht ohne bedeutung und
unsere treffen mit dem sinne und sie
schafft es auch aber ich glaube dass die
geschlechter gar nicht so ein thema sein
sollten ob man jetzt männliches oder
weibliches deswegen bin ich auch sehr
gegen zu ändern weil da wird ja auch mal
gesagt du bist ein mann du bist eine
frau und ich finde es nicht ich glaube
schon dass wir mit blick auf die
gleichberechtigung noch eine einige
kämpfe zu kämpfen haben ich würde zum
beispiel begrüßen die frauenquote das
alles staatliche betrifft also ich finde
staatliche institutionen sollten quoten
einführen das ist staatlich wir sind so
und die privatwirtschaft seien genannt
passiert so was wir in paris in paris ja
sogar frauen dann nicht mehr in
führungspositionen die verwaltung war
schon so wie frauen gab der parität
gesetze oder ist jetzt müssen wir da
rein und bundestag oder auf ich finde
aber im bundestag ich würde ja bedeuten
die wählerinnen und wähler haben mehr
die möglichkeit frei zu wählen wenn wir
sagen der bundestag ist paritätisch das
ja übrigens auch das was die grünen
anstreben aber der ganzen gesellschaft
aber im moment aber das heißt dann
müsste man sagen ihr dürft jetzt nur
noch ein mann oder eine frau wählen wenn
wir jetzt alles parieren die hamburger
auswahl zeichnet doch die demokratie
werden muss ist man muss auch sehen dass
es nicht nur eine parlaments sondern
universität auch noch obendrein genau
und es ist zum beispiel so von den
medien in der medizin humanmedizin es
ist bei den erstsemestern ist dass 75%
bis 80% der erstsemester studierenden
sind frauen inzwischen und das wird
langsam fast problem will ich nicht
sagen aber glücklich da
muss man einfach so da kann man eine
diskriminierung sage ich mal schlecht
aus machen und an der universität gibt
gilt es auch ein parlament gibt es
gerade die freie rede und ich finde das
gerät genau in diesem kontext und
überhaupt diese dieses also kanzel kalte
wenn man das jetzt auf macht das ganze
gerade an den universitäten ist eine
sehr gefährliche zu machen jetzt den
ganz anderen fass auf aber das dürfen
wir überhaupt nicht weil das sind die
anfänge die frage ist nach welchen
anderen kriterien will man dann man kann
das nach geschlecht habe ich kann ich
kann mir für andere anhieb fünf oder
sechs andere kriterien die ich einführen
könnte und das kann ja nicht
funktionieren ist vor allem auch eine
fehlentwicklung also wenn wir sagen die
menschen definieren sich nicht mehr nach
leistung so oder nach dem was sie als
mensch ausmacht sondern in erster linie
zählt das geschlecht in erster linie
zählt der migrationshintergrund oder der
ort in dem du geboren oder
das alter ist hier die eventuell
sexuelle orientierung die wird
mittlerweile auch teilweise schon
abgefragt bei einigen kongressen und
beim essen sehen wir zum beispiel das
jetzt schauspieler nur noch eine rolle
spielen dürfen wenn sie dieselbe
sexuellen orientierung haben aus
derselben region kommen selbst nicht
sagen und das ist auch unfair weil dann
heißt es ja okay die eine hälfte kannte
ich schon mal gar nicht um eine position
bewerben weil man in anführungszeichen
das falsche geschlecht hat und deswegen
müssen wir diesen fehlentwicklungen mit
aller entschlossenheit entgegen treten
oder mentor man die poeten die bei der
einführung von joe biden dieses tolle
gesicht auf englisch vorgetragen hat die
sollte das auf deutsch publizieren dann
gab s die übersetzerin und die war nicht
der teil der gleichen ebene und dann
wurde das unterbunden und jetzt gibt es
das deutsche die deutsche version immer
noch nie habe ich es ist natürlich
quatsch auch was dort an der universität
passiert aber ich glaube man macht es
sich immer sehr einfach indem man dann
alles also alles was total wir ist finde
ich auch alles wir die angesprochenen
beispiele durch möchte man also und sagt
man muss gar nichts mehr tun und das
sehe ich anders hat können frauenanteil
in der union ich kann jetzt gar nicht
genau sagen wie wir das in prozent unter
40 denke ich ist er in der fraktion aber
auch das war ja eine freie entscheidung
der wählerinnen und wähler das ist ja
nicht so dass irgendjemand das
vorgegeben hat ich bin jetzt zum
beispiel gewählt worden ich nicht soll
ich mich jetzt für mein geschlecht
entschuldigen die kurve ist die
unternehmen aber was ich bin da auch es
ist ein falscher ansatz zu sagen wir
machen von anfang an wollen wir ergebnis
gleichheit und alles soll gleich sein
was viel wichtiger ist dass alle die
gleichen rechte und gleiche chancen
haben das kann dann am ende zur
ungleichen ergebnissen führen aber
entscheidend ist dass alle gleiche
rechnung 2000 haben quoten in freundin
war wenn das das ergebnis freie
entscheidung ist ist das doch auch
unproblematisch ich möchte aber trotzdem
den frauenanteil höhen und was glaube
ich ganz wichtig ist in dem zusammenhang
und viel wichtiger als quoten dass zb
die vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
deutlich verbessert wird denn ich sehe
zum beispiel auch bei mir in
meiner generation zwischen 30 und 40 da
sind viele gut ausgebildete frauen nicht
sie haben eben erwähnt gerade im bereich
medizin deutlich mehr frauen als männer
und die haben auch häufig bessere note
und wenn die dann kinder bekommen haben
dann ist das häufig ein karriereknick
und daran müssen wir arbeiten das stimmt
aber das wollen wir nicht über
gleichmacherei und quoten erreichen aber
sie seien ja indem wir zum beispiel sehr
gute betreuungsangebote
garantieren es gibt zum beispiel jetzt
meine ich sogar an einigen universitäten
in münchen man ich eine fast 24 stunden
kita es gibt die möglichkeit dass zum
beispiel gerade auch für ärzte
angerechnet wird wenn kinder pausen oder
babypausen und das sind glaube ich die
richtigen wege die wir auch in viele
andere teile der gesellschaft übertragen
müssen damit frauen nicht sagen
entscheide ich mich für ein kind oder
entscheide ich mich für eine karies ich
würde die frage aufstellen wollen wir
dann in der medizin eine männerquote
einführen
wenn wir jetzt also es ist ja so es gibt
berufe ich einen neuen quoten einer
arbeitet der lehre berufen war einmal
ein männlicher beruf ist jetzt fast so
aus wie ich sein weil es selber wie
pastorin evangelischen pastoren ist auch
so die frage ist in der medizin ich
halte das für eine sehr ungesunde
entwicklung wo wir nur männer oder nur
frauen hätten und wir haben jetzt die
die anteil steigt jedes jahr ungefähr
drei bis vier prozent das heißt es
absehbar dass es bald kaum frauen gibt
in der medizin das ist keine gute
entwicklung und die frage ist sie
stellen nur die jetzt in der runde auf
wenn man sagt okay sie haben gesagt im
öffentlichen dienst und nicht ich
verstehe den unterschied ehrlich gesagt
nicht das müssen sie mir erklären
aber wollen wir jetzt in wenn es wenn es
berufe gibt die ihr dann in die andere
richtung gehen ist das auch eine sache
die man ansprechen sollte
ja ich habe leider noch 20
also zb so beim start empfinde ich es so
der wird ja auch vom steuerzahler
bezahlt die ämter da sollte man die
quoten einführen privatwirtschaft nicht